well I I'm puzzled I don't exactly
understand it but here's what I would
say that you have to under know about
Amanita mascaria number one it's
seasonally variant
number two it's geologically variant the
ones that grow in Appalachia are nothing
like the ones in the Pacific Northwest
and neither of them are like the ones in
Siberia okay so it's seasonally variable
that means earlier in the season it can
be stronger or weaker than it is later
in the season
and then the third consideration is that
it's genetically variable
so just the genetics of it can cause it
to be strong or weak well here we have a
three variable system in place already
and now you're going to drop into it a
fourth variable the vagaries of your own
personality while under the influence of
a strange and Powerful drug now we have
enough variables in the mix that we
can't predict where anybody's going with
it whether anybody's going to get high
or not
um I took it twice in my life
and once uh
uh it was simply a bellyache it was up
behind Boulder in Colorado and I ate a
dinner plate size specimen and had a
terrible stomachache for hours
a few years later
someone told me you macerated in hot
Brandy and then it's that's the way to
do it I hiked up Strawberry Canyon
behind Berkeley and set up my little
alcohol lamp and my Brandy and my whole
thing and did quite a slug of this stuff
and sat down on my blanket to make my
examination of conscience and await my
fate
and I closed my eyes
and nothing seemed to be happening and
about 20 minutes later I opened my eyes
and I'd lost 50 percent of my vision
it was coming in on me everything was
turning fuzzy and getting and then I had
to deal with the possibility can I find
my way out of here Stone blind should I
stay here
and go blind and then wait through the
blindness assuming it will pass and
assuming it's not going to be days or
what should I do and I and it was
somewhat of a panicky situation because
I really didn't want to sit there blind
as a bat for a day or two so I ran the
old Berserker myth I was able to summon
enormous energy to go leaping through
the dimly discerned Woods that were
fading out all around me and I got to uh
I got to a road and then I said well
okay now I'm at a road but I'm also
completely stoned and carrying on in
this outrageous way so I found a culvert
and crawled into the Culvert and then
went blind and stayed in the Culvert
about 10 hours and then crawled out and
made my way down the road saying you
know who needs this you know it was just
a completely
disheveling experience on every level
uh
once in a while you will meet somebody
who will just swear to you but this is
the finest thing around and I don't know
what to say to them I remember someone
came to a talk of mine and they talked
about how in New Mexico in the early 60s
there were a series of rainy years and
the Amanita came out and this guy said
he took it and fell into a trance and
when he awoke it was like a Jack and the
Beanstalk situation there was a tree
that went to the moon as far as he could
tell and as he laid there unable to move
but gazing at this tree which went to
heaven
several tens of thousands according to
him of elves appeared on the scene
journeying across the plain and when
they got to this tree
there there was a big pow-wow and they
wanted to climb the tree but then some
voices were raised among their number
saying you can't climb the world tree
wearing leather and so as he watched
hundreds of elves stripped off their
little leather Jerkins and their little
pointed shoes and their little caps and
were throwing them in big piles and and
climbing uh up the tree with their
little rear ends hanging out of the tree
like double Christmas tree ornaments
you know
was it enlightening what can you say
about an experience like that
so uh basically I
I what I think about it and I may be
number one dead wrong number two
parochial to the point of being almost
racist in this judgment
but I think what's going on is uh
you don't want to apply Siberian
standards to what constitutes great
entertainment
because things are dull in Siberia
and what they think of as a fascinating
Saturday night full of wild changes and
ups and downs most of us would find very
uh very trying
there's a lot of this the psychology of
pain and the interpretation of
Sensations within the body is very
different from people to people as
advanced by my story this morning of the
guys who slam each other on the chest
when Intoxicated by uh by DMT the fact
that they prefer to drink reindeer urine
with Amanita in it rather than I'm gonna
need a straight tells you that even
among the True Believers there's a
certain waffling on on how good this is
an example of how a very ancient how a
very ancient folk way can be
incorporated into our culture without us
even realizing it and is provided by
discussing Amanita mascaria if you go to
the Encyclopedia Britannica and you look
up Santa Claus they'll tell you that it
has to do with Saint Nicholas and it got
started in the 11th century and it's a
but when you look at the Santa Claus
story it's a perfect uh uh mythologium
to analyze from this point of view
because look what's going on with Santa
Claus first of all Santa Claus's colors
are red and white the colors of the
Amanita mascaria for sure
Santa Claus lives at the North Pole what
does this mean it means that Santa Claus
lives at the axis Mundi where igrazil
the Magic World Ash of Welsh mythology
has taken root Santa Claus flies this is
what Shaman do Santa Claus is the master
of the reindeer the animal most
associated with the Amanita mascaria
Santa Claus is aided in his work by
troops of elves and what is the work of
Santa Claus to build toys for children
remember the DMT things saying look at
this look at this well those were
off-duty elves clearly
um
and and so so here are all the motifs
and I believe that for children in our
culture that all the Chrysler stuff is
not what Christmas about Christmas is
about standing in front of the tree on
Christmas morning with the gifts arrayed
and the twinkling lights on well that
tree is the tree that the Amanita
mascaria forms its symbiotic
relationship to it's always Spruce or
pine that it has a mycorrhizal
relationship so the number of motifs
relating Santa Claus to a cult of
amanina mosquito there's almost nothing
but relational Motif there and yet if
you suggest this to people they just
back away in horror you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you